first we got executive producer Marc
Guggenheim its Allah company for self
NATO captain Oh captain Katie lot
you're braving route
maybe resistant sellers mr. Victor
Garber
bran brother
an executive super bill from her
all right look at you guys
congratulations you guys
and survived your second season yes you
broke on yeah Oh leave a few guys of
Mark bill how do you go about fixing
time till you know how to do it well I
don't know I need fixed time one episode
is done one of those I'm but we're going
to open with a direct pickup from the
end of season two and whatever fixed
time immediately but we will deal with
the issue of you know dinosaurs in Los
Angeles
okay that was something I want to ask we
call dinosaurs in Los Angeles Big Ben in
the skyline we clearly have paper to the
tigers how we are we going to see just
how that some things out across the
globe yeah well I mean fortunately we
have the time bureau now as we alluded
to in the normal sizzle reel that season
is really you know last season the
elections were the only game in town
they were the only people who could do
what they do now they're sort of
competing with the best of the brightest
and rip hunter have sort of
reconstituted sort of new version of
what the time masters were and you know
the existential question for our guys is
where do they fit into his new universe
because clearly we're not the best of
brightest know most tracks the foot
strap and you've got you've got the
challenge of that we were carrying the
damage that they've done but it can be
legends without a villain and what can
you tell us about what sort of villainy
we had coming forth oh well I mean last
year we loved having our
collection of bad guys and so we just
want to keep leaning into that idea and
drawing from familiar faces from from
the various TV shows you know we'd like
to have perhaps some non-human villains
what else community well you saw in the
teaser trailer that we're bringing Casa
from the Vixen CW seed series onto the
show as a villain and yeah we're really
excited about that and obviously we're
really looking forward to the inevitable
confrontation between the amazing
character and her grandma great
granddaughter and then we also have
another villain we can announce
filtering aristocrats we have forgotten
this okay I am so don't don't tell that
what chemistry okay okay aha
oh right yeah yeah yeah last time we saw
him he was in Miami 1987 wearing loafers
without socks yeah so yes I'll be
meeting a new version of damian darhk--
a little a silly little more formidable
yeah and he is so good Duff Bethel over
spam good guy yeah so he is out for
blood
and he's coming for Sara's like oh don't
put me in loafers ever again he's coming
for me bring help you know in an
aggressive way all right so we got
damian darhk-- on the back what else who
else is coming back oh and there is
another gentleman who's returning up not
as a member of our role of evil right we
know obviously a captain Captain Cold
and yeah you know McCrory needs his pal
but unfortunately he's not going to get
the version of his pal that he remembers
so yeah it could be eight where we were
obviously really excited to bring
WebWork back on the show you know but at
the same time we wanted to bring back a
different iteration of mr. stark and as
we always say chaos and merriment Wilson
yeah I mean yeah we loved having Arthur
get to play you know the photo film
student and in the people Revolutionary
War general
so whatever things give it to boring we
can always have somebody come back in a
completely different way which is a
great thing about our show well he's
also coming back to a different Nick
cause by the end of the season he had
developed a bit of a heroic side down
the hell was that that was what how how
does getting make you grow up a little
bit okay good become a little bit more
responsible
look it's just a process of make being
surrounded by people that his team and
the ship that be starting to realize
that maybe bother minutes and offend
Ford's his first real family and now he
started to evolve you know I used to
coming up I mean he's got more bad and
good it's just good but he's slowly
evolving from the caveman kind of
nicotine maybe you guys came aboard
early last season and let's give them a
round of applause
how was it joining a cat that had
already gotten their sea legs on the way
Ryder it was easy only because everyone
was really welcoming and kind and
everyone might converse us but I was
interesting because like we're all very
different people and reciting about this
occasion of the day with all different
points of our lives so we thank what you
do Adam but we all have this really
great coexistence in it it's awesome and
and they could not have been more
welcoming of me and yeah I think I'm a
PI the fact we're going to let off a lot
last season was also great if you don't
really enjoy the dynamics of the
individual couple which is how our whole
relationship it was like life fading
with vegetative our time every episode
when also different paths I was
opportunity and I got an implication and
also I want to congratulate maybe you
have been much like Brandon been
immortalized as a lego superhero mini we
got one congratulations
I'm not passing this out yeah I bet you
can get one you'd be surprised
actually last year it was Brandon to
hook me up I could not have won I need
Brandon and everyone alright let's talk
about Brandon Brandon Miree this guy can
not get a win he's you know he's always
the one that gets dumped on me like try
to reach out to Sarah she shuts him down
no Kendra they got a game she [ __ ] up
off man his suit gets blown up like is
this guy ready to be said you know it's
just kind of ready to kind of change
things up yeah writers yeah I was like I
was thinking I said you're going for
that like Keith bang I think everyone
else I brought that up at the end of
season one and two happened and I just
decided not to say anything
three because I've just accepted it but
you know it gets its kind of that the
nice guys finish last
in a way which I don't believe is true
by the way but we exemplify that a
little bit in the show but I think the
thing about Ray is blast doesn't have to
be laughs unless you view it as last so
you know ray kind of anything always
tries to find the positive and the
learning experience out of everything
and that's what you do in life because
you're not always going to win so you
got to get good at not winning and
figure out how to be okay with that
right so well practice with that job
great answer I'd write it right answer
well die hold up what spin it into gold
cut and now Katie the captain Hey how
fun if it be sitting in the chair
ah thank you
it is good yeah yeah I like some people
let's do and and Sarah has evolved so
much as well and you had some gorgeous
stuff at the end of the season
especially Katie Cassidy where yes I
feel like Sarah really stepped into her
power going forward how do you guys
realize like Sarah is now a formidable
leader how do you then Jeff do you know
my leadership
I feel like right with her for real
season two names on board you know they
might have found that through the Attic
but they do now usually it's been it's
been good so far guys on that having uh
you know lady you know in charge of bull
pen plus spike
I think it really works yeah that's how
a what can you tell us about this new
character is coming on because this is a
big deal it is a big deal I'm really
excited as her name is sorry she's from
the future than your future 2030 and she
is a powerful woman speaks her mind up
she's a hacker I think very cool and
she's going to be the lessons I think
it's 20 in 2030 right yes yes and she
sort of seen the fall out 2017 and she's
sort of investors dystopian future and I
think maybe they're going to butt heads
at first and yeah it's going to be
interesting to see how that unfolds and
how she becomes part of team who is she
most going to butt heads with who is she
month going to butt heads with I think
it's going to be raised positivity Oh
would you say that perhaps when they
come together they spark but I do think
that she she thinks that rather than
fixing the future or fixing history that
you should improve history because she's
seen how bad things can become so I
think they'll quite see eye to eye on
that and she might see maybe a little
glass half-empty producers it feels like
this is a very important character and
move on your part why is it why is this
the time to bring a character in I don't
know I mean we need to change the
dynamic on our ship because otherwise I
think it's you know the dynamics get a
little too staid and fixed and you know
we look at our guys like a family and
you
the real drama comes when you sort of
destabilize that with with with a new
person and yeah I mean the last year
again we were like the time custodians
just fixing things and like Tala said
you know we're realizing philosophically
maybe there's more that we could be
doing as a team and if we end every
season with our guys feeling really
great about themselves and so the trick
is everything that we kind of have to
break him down and give him something
you know room to grow and and she's one
who changed things and it makes them
look at themselves and challenges what
their purpose is you know to do more
than than Griffin is time Bureau you
know it's it's you know it's great to
bring the new people drive oh yeah run
you look a good money program is a lot
by watching on the monitor download our
severe watch good look at you do it go
back to friends like to plant go back to
bed but right Fred haha right when we
got right a friend Ren Victor one of the
nice things yes I was a lot of the nice
things that have been a part of the show
is watching you buy really click into a
very caring friendship it's not even
like a father-son thing and these guys
actually care about each other as
friends now when you guys don't get to
work together you feel like oh I know
we are yes of course yeah like we we go
on like a house on fire I get it I get
it yeah like it's always it's always
kind of kind of strange when we're not
we're not together lovely come a lot of
friends so I need to see me get them
it's a you know I was all I was started
out you know the the the mentor the the
wise old man and and then of course
what's what's been wonderful about doing
this is finding that you know Martin
discovers quite rapidly that he doesn't
know what he thinks he knows and and and
Franz and John Jefferson becomes his
teacher and it's interesting in life how
that happens in our real life as well
because I actually be so tedious about
the way I you know do things and Franz
would you say a lie not my mom and bro
bro Connell and that's a very service
thing but actually it's a very true
dynamic and I think so so whenever we
get to those scenes honestly it's so
easy we we always look forward to just
our to two character scenes because it's
it's effortless
and it's a pleasure to do and acting as
you all know is about responding to the
person you're you're acting with and
Franz is masterful and for a young actor
it's it's quite annoying
hey Phil do you want to tell Victor and
Franz what they'll be doing in Rio eggs
yeah we have a contact variety we may or
may not be able to afford we have a new
character called Firestein ha ha ha the
business though it was the Freaky Friday
sort of situation so getting ready to
impersonate one another help me
amazing huh we've got I had some
questions from Twitter people one of the
was will we ever meet Ray's brother
Sidney oh we have talked about this
actually we have a really cool store
line of planned for season 4 we
definitely want to do it in season 3 we
have you know we talked to Brent about
this is grounding ah now you're talking
about it so much
what I'm counting on it now I know I
don't know but because you know as we've
established in episode 110 Disney looks
just like Brandon so Brandon has to be a
play to parts we're very excited
that's pendulum right I've never done
asked for
okay so sorry some civilians up
white-white a ratio bargain and not now
come pour Ganga I know you had to keep
Malcolm alive because then he had to
possibly blow up an arrow
well yeah I mean it's really you know
it's a constant you can come you know
you can't you know remove Malcolm from
the timeline you can't remove Damien
from the timeline
eobard so we actually we talked a lot in
the room about whether or not eobard odd
there's a lot of back and forth and
debate and everything and at the end of
the day where we really came out was
there had to be some kind of major
consequence to at least one member of
the Legion of Doom as a result of their
actions but we love we love Matt
laughter how good is a man who's an
awesome yeah call me up after after we
wrapped in and he's like I'm just sad to
be you know lofty shows I'm like dude
like I pay attention there's a single
character on any of the shows who's been
killed off who hasn't come back in some
way shape or form including you you know
in Highland Park so nicely
oh it's funny every time every time
Katie Dante's character dies we have
here a raise okay all right she gets to
renegotiate wait guys my mom
Oscar agent is in there with the cosmic
hunter there was so much great fun this
even I feel like this was this is a show
that truly emulates what a comic-book
series would be like a print comic book
series you guys got to do so many cool
things and shooting some pretty rough
conditions
I heard your finale was actually that
battlefield with covered in snow the day
before he films they had to take a
blowtorch and milk all the snow so it
didn't look like it was freezing out
there
and you're shooting with all the doubles
you have to understand that it's the
most tedious process imaginable like you
have it's like it takes ten times as
long as it would do to shoot a normal
scene and just keeping track of who's
who and who was wearing which character
was from which episode like I mean we
would write scenes and have to have like
action figures just to keep track of who
is in the theme so yeah no small miracle
and yeah Nick when you signed on were
you aware that they would eventually get
ours or were you worried that I were
going to be like the Xander notice I
know I couldn't say anything because you
know mark ability to that whole speech
about not saying anything or you're
going to ruin everything
don't ruin everything by saying anything
so that everybody asks questions like I
hope I don't know but I'm glad the
powers are fun the the CGI is great
our guys great job put together this
field skeleton yeah I was super stoked
about it especially because mark showed
me a drawing on our first meeting I
think it was like a park like he took
the dry and then you put it on the
coffee day it was like this is what the
guys kind of look
I all made that feelin oh my god it's
pretty cool red okay good okay for the
original legends were any of you
concerned or do you feel weird kind of
rivalry when the Justice Society showed
up in such an addict such an attitude
like they were awesome so much better
than us yeah I think it's a little bit
they were so polished so yeah I think I
think we actually took offense to this
but they were awesome people we also had
an attendant made you join them so we
must got to attack yeah we encouraged
that we were not calling them the
Justice Society of America we were
calling them the Justice Society of
potential replacements oh well bail on
the panel here is the one that's been
mostly just keeping track of all the
time that you've gone through and
mistakes with the amazing history
personally no more personally in France
yeah Fran round I always say where am i
what am i doing now he always goes maybe
he printed pretty good radix really
friend is like yeah he brings it in from
like the other show franchised enduring
seems like this doesn't work because
flash sets that up in the air oh okay
here which means this products are going
to be in the shop yeah I'll be like wow
and what's going on this thing I'm
telling what's going on okay if you kept
track of all the historical figures that
sarah has flirted with
you got the I love me oh sorry showing
up and just like shooting a look or like
I have a World War one nurse gun I mean
Sarah she's just attracted to the person
care of you're like the Queen of France
or like some nurse working 9 to 5 like
she's just about the person you know and
she's all love in love she's got a lot
of love to do yeah enlightening women
left and right will we see Gideon again
in the flesh me me yeah yeah we we love
handles Everton who plays Gideon
actually you're going to see in the
season premiere there's kind of an
inside joke that Amy cooperated played
along with us to do so you'll be seeing
UBC more guinea and we love we have a
film for the better names if we keep
calling her flesh and blood Gideon which
is not good no we have to go to that
plus we love I've action what live
action Gideon real real Gideon so so we
have to you know we have to bring her
back we we really enjoy how to be me
actually not just sort of disembodied
voice on Michelle Nyce we're going to go
to audience questions so if you guys
want to line up back there we'll get
those one of the Twitter questions was
how is Sarah going to react to whoever
if she ever seen black pirate
I want to know - I don't know I think it
would be really hard because you see
this person you're like you're my sister
and there's so much love there and all
the pain and everything and to see that
person who's your sister and not be your
sister but I don't even know how how you
deal with that and like is she gone like
black silent like there's no Laurel land
in there like it's just black siren well
it's you know she's a different world
she's different or less she's she's you
know Laurel Lance no parallel universe
and that's actually a big question not
tons of air about but that's that's a
big piece of the story that we have to
tell with you know the new iteration of
Laurel which is how much of the Laurel
that you know in love it in there
anything right maybe I'll just be like
you look much like my sister close
enough okay all right we got question
back there
dramatic hello my name is Henley and you
might have alluded to this so I hope
we're not on the same track but you are
bringing getting back and one of my
favorite things about this show is
potential for harbouring game with all
the pretty big references so this arrow
hammer hasn't happened yet and we don't
know it's like Fedora is still around if
they inside joke I was worrying if we're
going to get a Romney meets Gideon I may
be Duran crossover if there's a lot of
opportunities look I we love those we
love are just Len jobs and stop you've
got one you got another prison one
coming up either feel free right
right actually don't know it's actually
my fault this is my dad
you haven't been set free of we lost
yeah you guys ignore it for you but
that's why that oughta follow along I
apologize you're going to love it though
when you do read a little about it sorry
you choose to uh yeah go ahead
hi hello my name is Julie my question is
will captain cold we only brought back
from his past or will he be able to
alter his the mighty returned or brought
back from the dead I'm going to go with
C on you bub
that's a great reaction it's better be
what I'm hoping your banana well I mean
first off Nix of Minority Report nerds
are wanted thank you for bisexual
representation on your show
get to see more of the bisexual side of
Sarah's relationship or any new bisexual
characters come onto the show I mean
it's definitely time for someone to I
think it's time for us there and maybe
settle down early you know I have a
relationship that's more than just a
role in the hand and it's hard when
you're traveling through time
you know if there's you sort of have
there's someone in every port but season
we're really looking I was like this
it's definitely been a priority of ours
this season to re-establish Sarah's
bisexuality I think if you were to just
watch season two it would be very easy
to get the sense of purpose like the
lining in 213 from ray about her being
bisexual it would have been easy to lose
sight of the fact that she's bisexual so
we are it's a big the important thing
for us this year to re-establish that
access aspect of her character a lot of
people are like she's only been with
women or why is she not with a man now
and I think the thing with Sarah like
she's not trying to fit in any label
like she's not trying to label label
herself like a she's into women at that
time it's not like oh well you're not my
sectional anymore it's like I am what I
am and that's from her it'll change and
it will be what it's trying to be
without being forcing it to be something
I think from where it's all about being
fluid and just being true to herself
has there been any discussion about not
Ryan more constantly I have I mean of
course there's going to be a discussion
with that discussion but their beliefs
discuss it we're discussing it now okay
I can't help you with it you're doing a
really good job I'm tossing this one
okay I was going over do you mark
now God knows we're doing great we
talked about and and Matt's best
currently busy doing something right now
but had really good conversations with
that everybody enjoys the sweet ride and
when as time travelers are you going to
have the DeLorean on a navy show very
good last question Bill's a huge Back to
the Future fan this is the first one but
we are having an eighties episode number
four we're going to be going back to a
sort of Amblin Spielberg sort of
stranger things yeah we're going to
investigating Ray Palmer's childhood a
little bit and try to understand it out
what form the man right and so bizarre
yeah I'm gonna meet your mom
Oh what's up fish come
Hebrew hey
and uh keep her away from Nick I got my
mom here is Ivan Imam bro all right with
that I'm going to wrap this up you guys
are awesome thank you guys
[Applause]
you